[Music]
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show or it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers I
would consider my guest today one of
those to tease out the habits for teens
thinking processes practices etc that
you can hopefully emulate or test in
your own lives my guest today is
Professor Tyler Cowen CEO w en that is
Cowan and his personal moonshot is to
teach economics or economics will clear
that up in just a moment to more people
than anyone else in the history of the
world and he might just succeed in
addition to his regular teaching at
George Mason University Tyler has
blogged every day at marginal revolution
for I want to say more than 15 years now
that's incredible
helping to make it one of the most
widely read economics blogs in the world
he's co-created marginal revolution
University a free online economics
education platform that's reached
millions and will no doubt reach
millions more he is also a best-selling
author of more than a dozen books
this man is an overachiever a regular
Bloomberg columnist and host of the
popular conversations with Tyler podcast
where he examines the work and world
views of underrated thinkers like
martina navratilova neal stephenson one
of my favorite writers Reed Hoffman and
many more his latest project is emergent
ventures a 5 million dollar fund to
support entrepreneurs who have big ideas
on how to improve society you can find
him on the web marginal revolution calm
conversations with tyler calm i highly
recommend checking out and on twitter at
Tyler Cowen Tyler welcome to the show
thank you to him happy to be here and
there are so many questions I want to
ask we have so many friends or at least
I would say fans of your work in common
like Ryan holiday and you have been
suggested and requested as a guest on
this podcast for a very long time indeed
let's start with my my first question /
area of confusion as you may have
noticed even in the introduction I
pronounced it differently several times
do you say economics or economics
probably I'm not consistent
and I don't think of myself it's doing
economics I think of myself is doing a
funny kind of philosophy with the
economy as the topic so my goal isn't
really to teach economics it's to
improve my own ways of thinking and
maybe people will learn some of that as
I go along
why use and I will flip-flop here why
use economics as the vehicle
what makes that interesting or useful
for example of thinking I'm stuck with
it at this point right so I think the
most efficient way of learning at the
margin for most smart people is travel
and I try to travel a lot but I don't
necessarily try to talk other people
into becoming economists when I was a
young kid I was a chess player and I was
very good at chess than I quit chess and
I took up economics and that has made
sense for me as a career but in a way
I'm not emotionally that wedded to
economics right
I think of anthropology is a more
fundamental way of thinking about humans
and economics indirectly is parasitical
on anthropology and we should all be
doing more anthropology and travel could
you explain what you mean by a
parasitical on anthropology so economics
the core insights are about incentives
right the law of demand price goes up
you buy less that makes perfect sense
but in anything but the simplest
contexts you have to ask how do people
even understand what the price is so if
a mother says to our kid oh don't do
that or you won't be allowed to play
outside you know what is the real price
does the kid really not get to play
outside ever again they get to play
outside even more the day after who
knows it's about how people understand
how they communicate with each other and
that is a kind of anthropology sociology
economics is embedded in those broader
social sciences so in my view you need
to be broad read a lot travel a lot kind
of be a bit crazy
I'm all for I'm all for the right kind
of crazy I think we will be examining
and exploring some nooks and crannies
that would qualify as if not crazy at
least weird that's the hope
part of the hope for this conversation
and I want to come back to something you
said or referenced which was playing
chess as a kid
so in the course of doing some research
for this conversation I came across
something that said you also played for
money what did playing chess end or
playing chess for money teach you what
did you take away from those experiences
or what impact did that have on you well
this may sound trivial but first it
taught me I could win and second to
taught me I could lose and those are
both very important lessons and it also
taught me I needed to be honest with
myself about why I was either winning or
losing and that there were real stakes
here so I learned that like at age 10 11
that was a great background and chess is
not forgiving of excuses right it
cultivates what I now call meta
rationality and you can't lie about how
well you're doing not not in the medium
term you have a numerical rating it's
pretty accurate right you win or you
lose you can't say the Sun got in my
eyes more than once
[Laughter]
you have you have many phrases that no
doubt we will be digging into or terms
could you elaborate on meta rationality
please or give other examples of meta
rationality a person is being met
irrational when he or she understands
how smart or well-informed he or she is
in a given topic area meta rationality
is very hard to come by in my view so
people typically do not defer to the
views of experts when they ought to
sometimes the expert might be wrong if
you're just but if you're just playing
the odds the expert is probably right so
people are far too confident about too
many things they shouldn't be so
confident about meta rational people who
are essentially impossible to find and
it's a margin we can be a bit more meta
rational they know to whom they should
defer or how to find out the right
answer and as someone who is
self-admittedly or self-described
hi pearl x'q a consumer of it would seem
vast quantities but certainly on some
level curated quantities of information
how would you think about as an example
because you've also written for the New
York Times a in 2013 about pandemics to
fight pandemics reward research now one
could argue that we're a little behind
the eight ball with respect to current
circumstances but as we're recording
this on Monday March 2nd how do you
yourself think about for instance
parsing information and sources related
to something like kovat 19 and I know
that I'm using shorthand but the the
viruses is sort of awkward to say so
I'll just use kovat 19 as a placeholder
for for this particular corona virus
that we're contending with the returns
to understanding how to build a good
Twitter feed are very high yeah and
right now many of us should be building
coronavirus Twitter feeds right yeah and
following a number of people like Helen
brands well and then people need to
trust you so the returns to being
ethical and keeping confidences are high
and then other people will tell you
things if you're at all known and then
you need to be meta rational and judge
you know which of them you should listen
to more some of that might happen
through whatsapp and then just at the
end of the day are not to get too caught
up in your own narrative you need to be
suspicious of stories you can dislike
the panic story there it's all going to
be fine story probably the truth is
somewhere in between but dominant moods
or emotions tend to sea-salt of us even
if we're very smart and often smart
people got wrong because they're just
better at feeding more information into
their chosen mood and then they aren't
likely to screw up so it's this very
careful balancing act across many
dimensions hmm how do you cultivate meta
rationality particularly when hopefully
taking into account incentives because
what I've noticed for instance is that
among the friends I've spoken to who I
all consider from the perspective of an
IQ test at least in intelligent pretty
far on the right
that there the conviction with which
they believe this is serious or not
serious often corresponds in some
fashion to how inconvenient or
convenient it would be or how much of a
financial sacrifice believing it is
serious and requires say self quarantine
or something like that would would cost
them from a business perspective how can
one cultivate the ability to remain met
irrational during times of duress or
panic like this and I know that's a very
jumbled question but I think you can
probably get what I'm grasping for maybe
a certain bit of obliviousness actually
is useful so you want to be plugged in
but also somewhat detached and so caught
up in your own thing your whole what did
I have for breakfast this morning
routine when am I going to get to shoot
baskets next that it actually distracts
you from too much emotional involvement
so Peter Thiel sometimes says you sort
of want to embody opposites in yourself
in some ways so this extreme involvement
in the processing of information but
also a fair amount of detachment maybe
is the best you can do if you can
achieve that
I think the returns to detachment have
gone up a lot with Twitter so Twitter is
fantastic but most people use it badly
and they hate it and they criticize it
and they waste time on it
but if you just use it as a truth
generating mechanism and use Twitter
search and mostly ignore politics on it
it's wonderful could you give an example
of of how you have used Twitter in in
that fashion what would be what what
type of truth might you type of try to
generate or identify through Twitter and
how would you go about it right now
Twitter search is mostly better than
Google search so take a topic you're
interested in which in this case could
be coronavirus right and just type it
into Twitter search every morning or
every evening and see what pops up and
then you're not restricted to who it is
you follow which is always going to be
limiting you'll sample different
opinions see how people respond you'll
be led places by happenstance that's
fantastic we didn't have that 15 years
ago
one of your most popular if not the most
popular post of yours in 2019 on your
blog was how I practice at what I do I
believe that's the name of the of the
blog post please correct me yes that's
correct
and to quote that blog post you wrote
recently one of my favorite questions to
bug people with has been what is it that
you do to train that is comparable to a
pianist practicing scales if you don't
know the answer to that one maybe you're
doing something wrong or not doing
enough could you elaborate on that
please well say you're a social
scientist or you're a writer or you give
public talks you are out there in some
way all of the time but if you look at
people like say what Kobe Bryant did or
what Martina Navratilova did they
practice to an extreme degree and that's
how they got better Martina was not
world number one player until she had an
intense regime of proper practice Kobe
the older he got he realized he needed
to practice more whereas a lot of top
stars actually practice less and they
coast on reputation and they have a
guaranteed contract so just everyday you
want to be reading you want to be
talking you want to be thinking you want
to be exercising and do it you know at
an intense a level as you can and just
try to do that all day long
and that's practice and you know one
hopes it will make you better it's not
for you to say but you know that's the
hope how do you practice your skills
what does what does scales look like for
you writing out large quantities of
material much of which I never use or
publish writing out different points of
view which are not my own is also a way
of practicing trying to talk to a very
diverse set of people in my case not
just academics not just people I went to
high school with say listening to highly
complex music I think is a way to keep
your mind active periodically reading
serious fiction I think of something
people stopped doing after they hit a
certain age maybe 30 or 40 but it forces
you to be open to the complexities of
how humans actually are
I recommend that too
if someone listening were a nonfiction
purist say they quit at 20 and that had
not been reading fiction since there are
any particular fiction books that you
might recommend for someone to use as
their re-entry to the world of complex
fiction or fiction overall I would have
to know their biography but I would
start with Harold blooms book the
Western Canon which has a list and
surveys a lot of his favorite works a
few of which are nonfiction by the way
and dig in there and just find what you
love and pursue it I think the greatest
writer is Shakespeare it's not
necessarily for everyone and if you did
not grow up writing and reading English
it's probably not for you but that would
be one start the Henry odd you know when
you say complex music what does that
mean to you Indian classical music I
think is phenomenal and grossly
underrated and it really forces you to
be in a complexity mindset Beethoven
late string quartets Bach the art of the
fugue atonal music Arnold Schoenberg
some of the stuff people don't like and
curse at and think has wrecked music I'm
all for it pretty much it's just really
really hard the sophistication of the
hand percussion and classical Indian
music I don't know much about other
instruments but the sophistication of
the hand percussion speaking as someone
who's become very interested in hand
percussion in the last few years is
mind-blowing it is it is unbelievable
how well developed the system of hand
percussion is in classical Indian music
just as one example it could be the best
music in the world and I wonder if it's
not related to Indian preeminence in the
world of tech hmm that's that's that is
that is definitely one I'll have to chew
on I I like I like that as a thought
exercise at the very least you spoke to
your writing and your writing practice
what does your daily writing practice
look like if it is indeed daily I make
that assumption that perhaps you're
batching your writing what does your
writing process look like it is daily in
an almost religious manner I
right on Christmas Day I write on
Sundays I write columns blog posts I
like to quit writing before I get tired
of writing that way I'm hungry to come
back the day after and the real enemy in
writing is days where you get nothing
written if you write something every day
I don't care how much or how little it
is it's going to add up and over time
you'll get more done each day so just
make it an absolute rule
the really important thing may not be
writing for everyone but just do it
every day I get better at it every day
don't take any excuses do it what does
your routine and setup look like what
time of day what what are the
ingredients that for you constitute a
writing session what are the
characteristics I love having multiple
offices to create variants and my
physical environment but usually I start
at home I have just an ordinary sofa
next to a very good stereo and a lot of
CDs some being Indian classical music
and I just sit on the sofa and lean
against the armrests I don't even know
if I'm comfortable but I'm so used to it
and I just write and I end up back there
at the end of the day and in between I'm
at you know one of my two offices or if
I'm on the road you know I'll write in a
hotel room I've gotten very used to
writing other places I enjoy the change
of pace
somehow forces you to think new thoughts
a bit do you do it first thing in the
morning does the time of day vary what
is the timing look like almost always
it's early in the morning the first
thing I do in the morning is check my
email and eat breakfast right but after
that I try to get to writing pretty
quickly so I think a lot of people peak
between say 8:15 a.m.
and maybe 11:30 11:45 and those are my
core writing times most but not all days
and when you check email do you have any
rules or tactics that help you to avoid
getting consumed or pulled into the
vortex of of an email to the extent that
it it overtakes your writing time how do
you think about that well keep in mind
email responding to emails is writing to
one said to Patrick Collison my business
model is responding to
email that's how I respond to a lot of
email I don't respond to it the second
it comes in necessarily and I certainly
don't in the morning but there'll be a
few things if only because of time zones
or I do respond immediately an email us
how people are going to tell me things
often so if I respond I develop more and
better relationships I'm you could say
I'm a fan of getting somewhat drowned in
your email but I think here's part of it
I try to stay a bit weird and obscure
enough that mostly quite smart people
are writing me and if I had too many not
smart emails I would feel I was doing
something else wrong with what I'm
writing what will be that what will the
symptoms be of you having crossed the
line into over overexposed or maybe
having made mistakes in your writing I
guess besides the email but are there
well you know well well the indication
be just a change in the ratio of smart
to not so smart email or there are other
ways that you would recognize you've
gone astray with your writing maybe too
many people asking me to do political
things would be a sign that I had done
something wrong that mostly doesn't
happen the people emailing me being less
smart or less to the point that mostly
doesn't happen so I think I get a pretty
large number of very good emails each
day or what's that messages and I like
that but you have to reciprocate right
yeah with your with your writing do you
do your drafting first drafts in Word in
latex in it email composition I know
some people who do that in an actual
word like a WordPress editor or in a
blog of some type how do you draft I'm a
software it so if I'm writing a book or
a column I just use Microsoft Word got
still struggling to figure out how it
works if it's a blog post I type it into
WordPress and I do find if I type into
WordPress I write different things than
if I write on an open Word document
recently I've been trying Google Docs
it's better for collaboration but it's
disorienting for
yeah it doesn't feel permanent somehow
it feels like if the quasar explodes
somewhere out there the whole thing will
go poof and I'm nervous but maybe that's
good Eli gets me to finish what I'm
doing more quickly now you have written
about your own 12 rules for life I
wanted to ask you about two of them if
you would be willing to to expand so
I'll read them but these are these are
rule 7 and 12 respectively and I'll read
both and then you can dig into either
the first number 7 learn how to learn
from those who offend you number 12
every now and then and I'm going to
mispronounce things here probably read
or reread Erasmus Montaigne Homer
Shakespeare or Joyce's Ulysses so that
you do not take any rules too seriously
the human condition seems to defeat our
orders are our temps excuse me to order
it all right I would love for you to
expand on on either of those you can
choose whichever you'd like to talk
about first well part of the brilliance
of those writers I listed is their
highly complex they force you or induce
you to see human motivation as very
complicated they run against the grain
of their being simple answers and you
really have to focus on them and give
them full attention so if you're dealing
with them periodically I think it's a
good way to always stay fresh if that's
a true open honest engagement now the
people who offend you I mean Twitter is
a great place to find them right people
are so negative on Twitter and either
directly or indirectly they're gonna be
negative about you whatever it is you do
or are or think someone's going to dump
on it and trash it those are the people
where you really need to look closely
and say what can I learn from this
person do not play a strategy which I
call devalue and dismiss because you can
point to flaws in their thought right or
their biography like oh you know say
what they've done wrong or they didn't
say this right three years ago and you
can dismiss them but they're at the
margin really the ones you've got to
learn from like for me that's Paul
Krugman you know he puts down so many
people sometimes he puts down views I
hold you could say it offends me but you
know I need to suck it up you know and
just
realize there's something I can learn
from here what have you learned from
Paul will be or cultivated as a result
of performing this practice well I would
say a lot about regional economics at
the meta level I've learned a lot about
how to communicate sometimes how not to
communicate I understand a particular
point of view much better which I
sometimes but not usually agree with and
he's one of the smartest economists out
there right he has a Nobel Prize like of
course my goodness we should be learning
from this person what what are things
that come to mind that you have changed
your mind on in the last few years or
the last year there any any positions or
beliefs or otherwise that you've you've
changed your mind on or come to think
differently about well one thing that
I'm finding really striking is the
number of different countries that have
had demonstrations or sometimes even
riots about their politics and those are
sometimes countries such as Chile which
at least in regional terms are leaders
are doing better than other places Chile
is actually seen declining income
inequality and yet millions of people
and a not so well populated country are
going to the streets so the sense of
discontent out there is higher than I
had thought and I don't feel I fought
that through properly yet but I'm
definitely changing my mind about the
stability of current parties and regimes
of politics it seems to not quite be
holding what are your working hypotheses
with respect to why that might be I
think one is the Martin Guri hypothesis
that in a world with the Internet we see
everyone's flaws more readily so you
look at politicians or for that matter
top thinkers on social media mostly
they're not very impressive and again
you could play the D value and dismiss
strategy but it means the citizenry ends
up disillusioned so the second point I
think is that if you look at say the
United States it is not in every way
covered itself in glory over the last
fifteen or twenty years and that
disillusions people around the world yet
they don't know where else to turn
because in my view some version of
Western liberal capitalist democracy is
indeed the best system people see China
doing better they don't necessarily want
autocracy so politics becomes more
confusing and then finally I think we're
seeing big shifts in the income
distribution where certain groups are
seeing either stagnant or falling wages
and this heightens their anxiety and
then they too become dissatisfied in
politics but they're not sure exactly
where to turn they tend to turn to
politicians who promised them free
lunches but that's probably bad hmm how
are you going to go about developing a
better understanding or different
perspectives related to this this
observation for instance in Chile what
what is what your next steps look like
well the most likely next step is
failure right knowing that she'll a
would be one thing I would do I've spent
maybe five weeks of my life in Chile
which is not a lot but enough that I
have a sense of the place I was recently
invited back I will try to find a way to
get back and then I will speak with
people but I also try to figure things
out just by writing them down or writing
them up and if I just sit in the shower
and sing I don't really get anywhere so
I need to talk with people or give a
talk or write something down and that
will probably be wrong but that's like
the draft that doesn't get out and then
it will get better and like maybe
sometimes it's okay
what percentage of what you write would
you say ultimately gets published on the
blog or elsewhere just to give people an
idea of what the pie chart two looks
like with published unpublished and
maybe there's there are other categories
but what percentage would you say end up
getting published somewhere it's hard to
measure because the things I discard I
tend to rewrite them so much whether
I've thrown them out or just rewritten
them I'm not sure how to classify it but
I have many hundreds of pages of
unpublished stuff and it's going to stay
that way in in varying phases of
completeness but it was necessary to get
to other things
in in 2000 I want to say 2003 so this is
some time ago suspect things may have
changed but at the time I read that you
were watching television only in Spanish
that was correct then yeah how long how
for what period of time did you do that
Oh over a dozen years and I still do it
sometimes but I found it a good way to
learn Spanish but a good way to have a
window onto a group of concerns that I
would not necessarily encounter in the
rest of my daily life so if you watch
Spanish language news from Latin America
or from Miami but essentially from Latin
America you will just get a very
different sense of what is important
what is interesting what is dramatic a
very different sense of the role of the
tragic how families fit together the
importance of children really shakes up
your worldview but mostly I wanted to
learn Spanish but I became a bit
addicted to it and I still do it when I
have the time I listen to the the
duolingo Spanish podcast sometimes for
similar reasons although it doesn't
provide quite it does in some cases
provide that sort of contextual temporal
news human instrument interest element
but perhaps less so than breaking news I
left premiere in Paco on Univision
I still watch that sometimes it's at 5
p.m. for me it's channel 14 it's just
fantastic what do you find to be the
benefits of focusing on language
acquisition or I suppose cultivation
well I only know two other languages is
English Spanish and German they force
you out of your comfort zone they make
you realize what an idiot you are you're
always learning something you get
windows and - how weather people think I
sometimes call it cracking cultural
codes Spanish is great because it opens
up a lot of different countries to you
German has some of the most profound
writing and music philosophy and culture
of human history I wish I knew more
so I envy people who know many languages
and people who have tried
you know two more in different places
than I have they're the people you
should envy I'd like to ask you about
one of your many books the complacent
class now my my my read and please
correct me if I'm wrong is that you've
you've argued that we've in some
respects become a stagnant and cautious
society what is that what does that mean
if I'm actually sort of interpreting
things correctly and feel free to
correct me we innovate less especially
outside of the tech sector our incomes
grow more slowly we move around the
United States at roughly half the rates
we used to we are now unable to pull off
grant projects such as putting a man on
the moon almost all of the spending of
our federal government is now locked in
and much of that most of that going to
the elderly we're just a less dynamic
society people are crazy how they bring
up their kids no risk is to be allowed
people obsess over what kindergarten
will my kid get into if they don't get
into that kindergarten my goodness all
is lost we are far more a society of
credentials which I regard as a huge
negative all of that and more what what
can one do is is are there any personal
actions that you would suggest to
counteract or counterbalance in some
fashion those societal trends I mean of
course that's more than just a side all
trend there are actual government
policies and so on but what can the
individual do if they listen to you say
this and they agree with you are there
any particular practices or steps or
recommendations that you absolutely this
Steve Levitt the free economics guy he
wrote a great paper where he took some
people and he looked at their major
decisions and for some of the people a
coin was flipped and if the coin said
they had to make a big change they made
the big change a next post the people
who made the big changes were happier
than those who did not so of course it
depends on the person and on the context
but in general read that Steve Levitt
paper think about the coin flipping and
more of the time
the big change of course it's a risk
right but it seems on average it pays
off question for you is the now those
were big changes determined by the flip
of a coin is that right right right okay
how much of the happiness with the big
change do you think was from making the
big change or being absolved of the the
buyer / sellers regret equivalent
second-guessing in other words a
decision that you had to make on your
own I don't know but if it's only the
being absolved that matters well treat
me is the villain and you are hereby
absolved from responsibility just say
Tyler made me do it
and they'll often be happier and the
rest of society will do wet do better as
well what are some of the major
decisions that you've made that have
been extremely impactful in your life I
decided that I would really focus on the
Internet and giving away my output for
free and mostly stopping doing
peer-reviewed scholarly research and
devoting all my time to blogging and
online essays and online education in my
podcast and that has gone phenomenally
well for me when did you make the
retrospect it doesn't sound that scary I
started blogging I think 17 years ago
and the notion that I would do this
every day for what is now almost 17
years at the time was extremely weird
and I was doing well in my other
endeavors it wasn't there was some kind
of failure that need to be patched up
but I just thought I'm gonna do this I'm
not gonna look back at first like no one
paid any attention for years I just kept
on doubling down happily you know in my
oblivious fog and it worked out great
so so I'm gonna push back a little bit
on the oblivious fog you're a smart guy
you're you're you're able to I think
they say I was a meta rational guy you
said like a smart guy maybe I should
know well I was going to bed irrational
next that was my second compliment how
what was your decision-making framework
for for doing that 17 years ago
so that places us around
three roughly right how did how did you
make that decision which at the time too
many very smart I will use the word
smart here colleagues probably appeared
absurd how did you what was your
decision-making framework or how do you
think about making that decision I'm not
even sure I had a decision-making
framework I think in a way I'm
dysfunctional as a decision maker at
that level I like did it for a day I
enjoyed it and I just didn't stop doing
it and a very selfish curious greedy
with information way and it would just
became quickly impossible to turn that
ship around so I thought well I've got
to do more of this and I mean I would
hesitate to recommend my so-called
decision-making process to anyone what
was the the positive feedback loop on
the daily experience that kept you going
for years before it seemingly game
gained traction
what was it that appealed so much to you
for three or four years like we had a
few thousand readers but it wasn't a
thing and it hadn't taken off it was
fine and when I started I thought oh it
would be awesome to have only five
thousand readers like some kind of
utopian dream but I lost track of that
and I just ran by with learning things
having to write all these posts like oh
I need to learn this I need to learn
that and then when I would write on it I
would change my mind so I thought well
this is some form of progress and again
just struck at it and then later like
blogs became a thing and even though
blogging is mostly disappeared it's gone
very well for us we've played a kind of
last-man-standing strategy and we
haven't like seen that kind of cut back
in readership I think it's it's it's
lost some of its newness sex appeal but
I would be astonished if long-form
or even not so long form writing as long
as it is of high quality for considered
of high quality for at least a few
thousand people or even less I don't see
that going away anytime soon
I know that there are other meaty any
other forms of media that are more
fashionable perhaps but I'm certainly
not concerned for the longevity of your
readership I think you'll be fine
how have you thought about branching out
from the written word and making
decisions about that well I do now a
podcast every two weeks that's called
conversations with Tyler and that keeps
me very busy and dominates a lot of my
reading time you know that's for free
it's not a business for me it probably
costs me some money but I find I read
much better when I'm reading their work
to go and interview them so next I'll be
doing Philip tetlock the guy who writes
on prediction and super forecasters that
will force me to get my thoughts in
order on those topics after that I think
it's Emily st. John Mandel who wrote
station 11 which coincidentally is a
book about pandemics and she has a new
book out I read fiction much better when
I know I'm talking to the author himself
or herself when I interviewed Martina
Navratilova
to learn a lot about history of tennis I
read like 50 books on the history of
women's and also men's tennis that was
fantastic
I wouldn't have absorbed them in the
same way if I wasn't going to be
speaking to her so I'm just keep on
doing these podcasts again totally
dysfunctional decision-making on my part
well we'll see you could certainly have
good outcomes with bad process but I'm
not totally convinced it's bad process
but it's not something I could explain
or justify in terms of a model of
rationality right it's also low risk in
the sense that I mean the max downside
risk of doing this is is very it would
seem very low whereas a lot of the
benefits as you said putting a putting
an incentive and deadline in place so
that you immerse yourself in these
topics and worlds that you might not
otherwise put so much energy into is is
certainly a benefit how did you prepare
for Neil Stevenson because I've read
Neil's books and for people who don't
know you have snow crash Crypton nomicon
you have many others and these are these
are not short books these are in
in fact incredibly long books in many
cases how did you prepare for that
interview he was in some ways an easier
than usual prep because there are many
Neil Stevenson books I already had read
which was a huge head start just as
you've read them and then there were
others that I simply cannot read like
Anitha which I suspect is brilliant but
I'm just not a good enough reader or not
smart enough or not something to get
through it it just loses me and I've
tried at least twice I tried again to
prep for him I couldn't read it and it
might be his best book so I just had to
put that one down and I figure well this
is Neil Stevenson I'm just gonna talk to
him about stuff a lot of the obvious
usual questions about science and the
future and technology and he'll just be
interesting so that was I wouldn't say
easy but easier than many whereas people
who know a very direct thing like Emily
Wilson
she was the translator of Homer's
Odyssey I had to know Homer's Odyssey
really really well like that's what she
does I can't just blah blah blah or her
about you know what do you think of
Peter Thiel and the tech stagnation
debate we talked 85% about Homer's
Odyssey that was one of my hardest preps
hmm by the way if you ever want to have
her on but it's really tough I spent
months of my life preparing for her and
it was over in an hour yeah that's it's
it's better better ratio than the
Olympics I guess yes how are you
preparing for the conversation about
well I suppose it's not gonna be limited
to but station 11 if I'm getting that
that that right and pandemics what do
you what is what is how are you thinking
about navigating that conversation and
preparing for it I watch her on YouTube
I read all of the interviews with her I
can find online her two main novels I
will read twice and her earlier less
well-known novels I've read once and
she's from Canada I need to think about
Canada where she grew up in Victoria
what her literary inspirations are ask
her about those reread books that she
has read think you know I looked again
at Michael
kryten's the under dramatist rain she
wrote a novel about a pandemic well now
I have to think about boccaccio as well
right and you just have to like dig deep
into all your resources like what have I
got here and we'll see how it goes but
she's a hard prep you you have read I
mean you and Patrick Collison are sort
of birds of a feather here for people
who don't know Patrick Collison of
stripe in that you are voracious readers
and consume more books than the next 10
people put together and the next 10 high
achievers put together I think many
would say what are the books that you
have gifted or recommended to people
most that come to mind I know that you
have a huge sort of pantheon of options
available but what what books have you
recommended most to others we had a
couple come up earlier in terms of
people who might be interested in
exploring fiction or complex nonfiction
what other books come to mind if any I'm
very suspicious about recommending books
to people because there's the risk they
might listen to what you say and if
you're recommending to them the book
that is not like the most valuable next
book they should read in a sense your
wronging them so I don't give people
books that often I one thing I try to
encourage people to do is to read more
about music in the arts not a particular
book but I say take the creator's you
love whoever whatever they may be and
read about them if it's the Beatles
great if it's Beethoven and really dig
into what you might think of as your
hobbies but to read about them in an
intense way and just think about like
Beethoven how did he manage his career
like what were his productivity tricks
what did he do wrong and think through
some of the questions you've written and
talked about at length but in the
context of your cultural heroes if it's
like why do I tell people to read most
often you know I am NOT myself religious
but usually I'll tell my non-religious
friends they ought to go read the Bible
mm-hmm
it's a wonderfully deep and brilliant
book and most non-religious people even
most religious people barely know it or
Shakespeare
if someone said they said to you they
wanted to become more meta rational if
that were their of jet their stated
objective are there any resources you
would point them to or practices again
I'd like to know where they are starting
from but spend some time sitting down
with groups of people you don't usually
sit down with is my most likely
recommendation and that will depend on
the person so there's one colleague of
mine I'm telling him you need to travel
to some very poor countries and sit down
and speak to some very poor in terms of
income individuals and that's what I
think he should do obviously if someone
they grew up in the slums of Mumbai
that's probably not my advice right what
if they were well-to-do Manhattanites oh
my goodness like who felt like they were
who felt like they were prone to
confirmation bias due to various
incentives they had so they would sort
of they've embedded themselves in a
position they have stories they've
believed maybe their stories from their
parents who knows yeah what's the
besides spending time with someone who
is from an income perspective poor what
what other advice might you have for
such a person well if you're a man hat
and I you actually will be in proximity
to a fair number of or rare people but I
find on average Manhattanites tend to
think the world comes to them and I
suspect this is a delusion of sorts so
people say oh Silicon Valley's a bubble
well maybe but people in Silicon Valley
don't actually think the whole world
comes to them they realize they're in a
very special part of the world and I
think if Manhattanites would realize
that more they would then just leave
Manhattan if only to the other boroughs
I mean try Staten Island right don't go
to Paris don't go to London
try Staten Island West Virginia
somewhere like Macedonia and don't think
all these things are already coming to
you in Manhattan because they're not
you're getting a super filtered version
it and you're just seeing a more
Manhattan nothing wrong with that I love
Manhattan grew up in New Jersey but a
lot of remedial work probably needs to
be done what what are you working on
personally right now are there any
particular problems or sort of personal
development objectives that you've set
out for yourself well I'm writing a new
book and it's on what do the social
sciences know about spotting and
evaluating talent
and I have a project emergent venture as
you referred to before or there's a fund
of money I give away to individuals who
are talented or I hope they are talented
so really just trying to get better at
that and trying to get better at
communicating what I know or think I
know to other people and that's very
hard there is no single really go-to
source on how to evaluate talent people
who have not yet succeeded but maybe
they will I'm just pausing to think for
a moment here what have you learned
about interviewing if you look at let's
just say from either pre podcaster right
now or first few episodes of the podcast
- right now what what have you learned
about interviewing or how have you
improved as an interviewer and and you
can interpret that however you like
because there are many different types
of interviewing I'm not sure I've
improved hard for me to say but I think
getting people to talk about what they
do actually do tends to be good
getting people willing to be weird
getting people to be conversational
getting people to be engaged in
passionate the worst question is please
tell us about your latest book I try to
start with something super specific
something they're shocked that I might
know about them and then just you know
dig deeper how do you get them to be
willing to be weird well most of them
are weird to begin with right
so that's like a big force on your side
being weird yourself by relaxants the
environment it makes it non-threatening
just signalling you're not there to you
know screw them over that you want to be
there to be weird with them and that
you're actually doing this because you
enjoy it and usually it works not always
some people just like clam up they think
they're going to get a government job
someday
why not to have them on right
what does weird mean to you how would
you how would you define weird well in a
sense it's the weird that is truly
normal it's how people actually are like
what they really care about think about
so in a sense you're getting them out of
the weird the weird is the stage
presence we put on and all the puffery
and unwillingness to say what you really
think because my confirmation hearing
whatever so once you stop seeing the
weird is actually weird I think that's
also a help it's like this is natural
let's just do it and most people respond
to that I think but you do many of these
yourself right I do I'm not convinced I
know what I'm doing either I I somewhat
selfishly have surrendered to following
personal interests in interviews with
the assumption that if I find it
interesting I have at least a guaranteed
satisfied audience of one person but I I
think I have a pretty very particular
personality that then imprints my
approach to asking questions but I'm
okay with that I don't have a desire to
be anything other than Who I am at the
moment when it comes to asking questions
at least I never have a guest on you
don't care about right yeah a good rule
it is a good rule what other what other
rules have you developed if any you mean
in podcasting converse yeah let's get to
the point immediately the old saying
personality is revealed on weekends I
think you present a version of that in
one of your books yeah what is the
person do on weekends probably the same
as what they do on weekdays but bring
out that side of them right and just
asking the person in essence what are
your open browser tabs right now it's
one way of getting at
who they are browser tabs don't lie
right yeah that is a great question that
is a really great question so part of
the reason not surprisingly then I might
be asking this so that I can borrow and
use in the future but the future is now
so here we are a few seconds after you
just said that what are some of the open
browser tabs on your computer twitter is
always open WordPress for blogging is
always open several sets of email always
open whatsapp always open and then right
now I will have typically five or six
tabs to specific articles which at the
moment are all coronavirus that's a
typical usually they're more varied but
right now there's two big stories
there's the election campaign season
which I hate following and don't really
write about and coronavirus so it's
going to be coronavirus what are you
what are you reading about coronavirus
this is of great interest to me I've
been tracking it very closely for a few
weeks and I know this is topical but I
do think that in a sense there's a
parallel to the expression and I'm going
to butcher this and I'm afraid I don't
know the attribution but that adversity
doesn't build character it reveals
character and I do think that with the
let's call it threat on one hand panic
on the other and they're not totally
separate everything going on with
coronavirus the challenges of parsing
good from bad information reliable from
unreliable information many of the
frailties and thinking or logic or meta
rationality that otherwise would go
somewhat unnoticed day to day are
becoming much more pronounced in a lot
of people and many of them and maybe
present company included or not aware
just how those things are manifesting so
what are you what are you reading and
how are you thinking about this this
particular coronavirus we're speaking in
very early more
yes and it seems to me there are several
distinct episodes one is Wuhan there's
other parts of China the South Korea
Japan Singapore northern Italy
Washington State
princess time and cruise ship and the
different numbers from these separate
locations they don't really add up
no so I'm treating it like a Sherlock
Holmes puzzle how do we make sense of
all of these collectively comparing them
to each other so yes of course there are
data mistakes but what's your theory of
data mistakes where they all fit
together and I still actually don't find
a way of making it add up so I'm trying
not to approach it as like a lecturer
like telling everyone do this don't do
that wash your hands probably good
advice but there's a kind of puzzle and
to stay open about it and see what it
brings me and also see which of the
responses are the best ones so far
Singapore is looking quite good but you
know there's plenty of play left so to
speak and the United States it seems has
let the coronavirus get into its health
care system and it did nothing about it
for six weeks in what could end up being
really a kind of huge crime of omission
yeah you know I'm struggling with with
where to go with this because you know I
recognize we have a large audience
listening how do you how do you
currently plan to increase the
resolution on those puzzle pieces or to
continue informing yourself in such a
way that the picture becomes clearer and
not more difficult to make out how do
you think about information consumption
there's more data every day and I will
write out the puzzles as I find them and
try to think them through as I write
them out and then get feedback and I'm
not sure where I'll arrive with this one
hopes of course it just goes away and
the puzzles remain that puzzles at this
point that's seeming a bit less likely
than it had been so I'm afraid to say I
think we're going to find out more than
we want to know you know I'm not really
worried about
like if it all remains unresolved I can
just go away and celebrate right aside
from my for instance I mean Johns
Hopkins has a very good daily newsletter
which I would consider reasonably
uncharged politically speaking
you had mentioned someone on Twitter who
you follow and I'm blanking on the name
it's Helen Brown's whale she's public
alpha in Toronto how do you spell that
last name it's BR ans wel L I believe
are there any other particular sources
of information or other people you are
following who you find to be reasonably
level-headed about how they're
approaching and analyzing this there's
four or five I don't remember their
Twitter handles by memory but you know
they're in the list of people I follow
if you just go through that it will be
pretty clear which ones they are
okay great and then I find by being out
there writing about it in an open non
hysterical way I'm just sent a flood of
useful information yeah and that's
arguably my main source and I don't mean
to say I trust it all but you cross
check and you think and then you talk to
people you know and you get a bit
further yeah
why did you well I'm also assuming then
this was your initiative but why did you
choose to create emergent ventures how
did that come about you have a million
projects why have another one and why
this one there's a whole world of
philanthropy out there and I think it's
one of the least well functioning
sectors of the American economy you
can't blame it on government it's not
it's not that heavily regulated right so
much of it is bureaucratic and
risk-averse and people doing the same
things and I thought let's go back to
earlier models of giving from the
Renaissance or the 18th century where in
essence there was no bureaucracy one
person who says yes or no we don't ask
anyone for
we don't ask anyone about credentials do
you have a PhD whatever
it's basically 1,500 words tell us who
you are and what's your story and what
you're going to do and people can use
that space more or less as they wish we
ask them like tell us one value that you
consider to be a value we have that
question and we've now had about 80
winners and we got them a check in
essence how long how many applicants are
you vetting those 80 from I think it's
about 800 now
so there are most the rate of good
applications is reasonably high maybe
I'm lowering it just by talking about
the program but we've had even though
it's only about a year and a half old
we've had people go on to you know start
companies successful ventures people end
up in high positions in governments a
lot or just travel grants for young
people people who are safe from ages 15
16 up to 20 who get to meet mentors I
hope it's changed the course of their
lives those are often travel grants to
Silicon Valley but it can be anywhere
really and there's a - researchers at
Dartmouth they've created a kind of
Wikipedia like structure that now
contains data about every Indian village
in essence not every village is filled
in but we have the capacity to create
and store and use demographic data about
every Indian village this is a
not-for-profit venture I think it will
greatly improve public health and policy
making in India in the future there's a
fellow who is starting a kind of charter
city in in Zambia with Zambians so many
exciting things going on there young
Indian woman I think she just turned 18
starting a bus company she's raised
really quite a bit of venture capital so
for me it's a very exciting rewarding
thing to do I'm paid nothing to do it
the evaluator is me there's no panel
there's no bureaucracy
it's thumbs up or thumbs down and I
think far far and more philanthropy
should work this way
what will success look like or how how
do you and it could be just a subjective
feel but how do you determine whether
this program has been successful over
what period of time so many people in
philanthropy obsess over measurement and
I end up tending to do the same thing so
I'm actually at my margin somewhat anti
measurement I don't want everyone to be
anti measurement but my view is if I
need to measure you failed all right
so if I supported Malcolm Gladwell right
when he was a kid
well could I then measure how many books
he sold I mean I could try but it's like
come on it's Malcolm Gladwell if you
need to measure it out so that's my
simple rule you know we'll see I may
never know of all of the many many many
many if you look at rather the posts
you've put out the classes you've taught
the books you've written what are some
of the views that you currently hold or
still hold or perspectives that are most
controversial would you say meaning they
just they seem to kick the hornet's nest
wherever that hornist harness nests may
be what are what are some of the views
or beliefs that are most controversial
you know in the world of 2020 were the
two leaders of the two parties at the
moment seemed to be Donald Trump and
Bernie Sanders I no longer know what is
a controversial view in fact I used to
know what my controversial things were I
think in general we should do much more
to boost the rate of economic growth
devote fewer resources to the elderly
and much more to the young and take more
chances and travel more and learn other
languages and be much much more
interested in foreign cultures I'm not
sure those are controversial they're
obviously not controversial with a
sliver of a particular demographic but
I'm not sure many people really mean
them either so maybe my most
controversial view is it's no longer
clear what our controversial
these are so I would love to ask you
because it's it's I think easy to be
intimidated by how much you do and
certainly seemingly do very very
successfully you you're able to digest
sort of nonfiction pages and seconds and
[Music]
sort of aggregate data from disparate
sources into coherent blog posts that
influence millions of people ultimately
and so on and so forth I'd like to try
to offset that with a discussion doesn't
have to be long but a discussion of it
of a tough time or a failure that you've
experienced and specifically if there is
a favorite failure that comes to mind
meaning a failure you experienced which
was very difficult at the time or just a
dark period that somehow set you up or
contributed to greater success later if
that makes any sense yes you know I feel
I've been very fortunate in life and I
think I have about the most even
temperament of anyone I know like I
literally don't have unhappy days it
would be hard to say I've had zero in
life but I think I'm almost weirdly
never unhappy in a way that's good for
productivity but maybe almost inhuman
and to be a little bit feared or look
down upon or not thought well of I think
that's a better way to think of me than
to hear my like story of failure like a
few years in graduate school yes I felt
pretty lonely I didn't have a girlfriend
I was like a nerdy kid that was bad for
me I mean that would be the best I could
do and that's like so cliched and kind
of pitiful I don't know like the big
life setback tale not sure what that's
supposed to be well it's surrender
that's a weird answer but it's weirder
than it sounds I would
just say have you always been even
killed in that respect is it just out of
the womb that was your that was your
your programming or is that something
that you developed over time both I
think that was my natural inclination
and just as you mature you become more
that way but I've always felt pretty
happy I suspect my peak happiness is
well below that of most people hard to
prove that or measure that but
intuitively when I see people very very
very happy it's quite strange to me I
feel gee I've never felt this but saying
when people are depressed so I think
think my range is compressed in an
unusual way
so if for many people they strive to
feel happy or perhaps more accurately to
not feel unhappy right and much of their
decisions many of their decisions and
behavior are kind of governed or driven
by that are there any feelings that you
prefer not to feel that come to mind I
mean is is there something for you that
is analogous to unhappiness for other
people well I feel guilty about my
numerous shortcomings when it comes to
behavior so for instance I think to eat
animals raised under terrible conditions
is wrong but still mostly I do it I've
tried to improve I've improved somewhat
but I'm reminded of that regularly by
what other people do or right and I just
think that's wrong I think I fall short
I guess I at this point I have to
conclude I'm too selfish to change it so
I feel bad about that but it mustn't be
that bad right and I feel bad that I
don't feel worse about it as well you
could always do more for charity right
so yeah that's another it's like never
enough is it for people who wanted to
develop a greater a higher level of
equanimity McAleese they said I want to
train myself in some fashion to be more
like you Tyler in in in so much as I
don't experience at least the
the acute lows that perhaps I
experienced would you have any
recommendations for for those people are
there any particular any particular
suggestions reading resources anything
whatsoever that what that would come to
mind that you've seen help other people
well I'm not gonna say like go read the
Stoics I mean Ryan Holliday can tell you
that no Ryan's got that covered
yeah yeah but I feel a bit the people in
that position it's like they want a kind
of talisman almost like a voodoo object
yeah and I don't know if they really
want to be more detached and
dispassionate or they just want the
talisman and maybe my advice would be to
think through do you just want the
talisman that's fine don't feel bad
about that but like there's a really
cheap and easy way to buy the talisman
like buy one of my books read my blog
that's free yeah and you know pat
yourself on the back and go away and
forget that was your original motive if
you really want to do it I don't know
probably the fact that you're asking is
a signal that it's someone more in the
talisman direction well what is could
you elaborate on what you mean by
talisman Emily st. John Mandel just
tweeted I think this morning that
there's this risk of a pandemic with
coronavirus and she wrote a novel about
a pandemic that is really truly horrible
kills most people in the world and she
can't understand why her book is selling
so many more copies now I suspect people
want to buy it as a kind of protection
against the worst case scenario like
they feel they faced up to it they own
it a bit they control it I think I used
the Voodoo analogy a bit earlier and
thus they're a bit safer we sometimes
use comedy this way or see horror movies
for similar reasons and that's a
talisman you do it for a complex
psychological reason to process an idea
and be done with it and not necessarily
to really incorporate what's there and
that's fine I don't think we should look
down on that but you know if someone
asks I'm going to say is this a talisman
or do you want the real thing
well what would what would distinguish
those two within the context of the
question I'm asking so I'll I will just
because you brought it up mention for
instance the Stoics so I do think that
and we don't have to belabor this point
but the fact that I asked about
resources why would that indicate that I
want a talisman or I'm seeking a
talisman if I have found the regular
review and practice of say stoic
principles to actually be of great
benefit much along the lines of a
cognitive behavioral therapy or
something like that so I I do think that
has impacted how I relate to the world
and relate to others in the world so I
would say that that has tremendous
practical value so sure I'm Pro talisman
but I think you know it's like therapy
there's two reasons you might go to
therapy one is to feel you did something
about your problem and that could itself
make you better and the others your
actual conversation with the therapist
is useful you know with operate there's
nothing wrong with the talisman use of
therapy and with the Stoics probably
both operate you know great the talisman
actually makes the Stoics better in fact
they're good for two things not just one
well I guess I'd love for you to just
elaborate on why that use that I
described is of the talisman variety
that could be real learning right but
that yeah the version of the talisman
use of the Stoics would be that X on day
you feel a kind of personal and social
anxiety that you haven't done enough to
calm yourself and maybe you're just
never going to be that calm but your
meta anxiety about not having calmed
yourself you can lower perhaps by buying
and reading the Stoics you'll forget
what they said on a test three years
later but at the end of the day you did
something you went through a process you
had a mastery over some part of your
life and you feel better and the
anxieties diminished I think that
happens quite often in addition to
whatever you learn from them do you feel
like you have such talismans in your own
decision-making or behaviors or is that
oh of course sure no reason to think I'm
any different and a lot of the books I
read maybe if I felt something's I do
there's this book out there Tyler you
haven't read it yeah and I go read it
I'm not saying I learned nothing from
the book but part of the enjoyment
is the alleviation of the anxiety right
right sure oh yeah
too many books are like that like I wish
more of them had wonderful incredible
content how do you choose your guests
for your podcast mostly the people I
want to speak to and the people I wish
to prepare for so there'll be a lot of
economics some public figures people who
have written novels just people who know
a lot people who are what I call info
vores people who are intense or curious
it helps if they're nearby so I do all
of mine face to face a few of them are
public events so just like can this be
pulled off is a big question
doing Kareem abdul-jabbar that was a
dream for me I watched him when I was a
kid to play basketball and I saw his
last game in the NBA I had a chance to
do Kareem how could I not do that
trying to get William Shatner now
probably it will fail I don't care how
old he is he's William Shatner who are a
girl who are other people on your dream
list on your wish Lyon Eno the british
musician i sent i had an email forwarded
to him and i'm still waiting for him to
respond he strikes me as the kind of guy
who might respond seven years after the
invite most people it's like if you
don't hear in a week you figure it won't
happen this is brian eno
he could respond at any time with either
a yes or no for you he talked a bit
about the the changes of perspective or
changing your mind on anything
and you mentioned I guess it was
regional economics and we spoke about
Chile are there any new behaviors that
have been particularly beneficial for
you that you've only started in the last
year or a handful of years any
particular new behaviors or habits that
have had a non-trivial impact on your
life it's hard to tell I've spent more
time with weights as a form of exercise
I vaguely feel it's helped I don't have
any measurement I could cite for you
and how if my behaviors changed in the
last year eating smaller portions of
food which I think has helped you know
my diet is just eat what you were gonna
eat but eat 2/3 of it right and I've had
the discipline to make that work you
don't have to fuss over what you're
gonna cut out right you just divide by
2/3 and just trying to be kinder to
people again I'm not even sure I'm
managing to try to do it but that's like
always a priority or sometimes a
priority what is what does that look
like being kinder to people or white why
did that become something of focus for
you if you can be encouraging in a non
trivial way it can really mean a lot to
people and it takes several kinds of
effort this effort in the moment but
also the skill of how to sincerely have
a sense of what would be the encouraging
thing to say and it seems to me that's
greatly undersupplied in the world and
like some of the things that are
undersupplied or just people telling
other people what they're good at which
happens plenty but really kind of
accurate incisive this is what you're
good at and why greatly undersupplied
supplying people especially younger
people visions of what they could be
greatly undersupplied but you also want
to be better at it rather than worse
right so making that more of a priority
and some of the grants I've given out
through emergent ventures to younger
people I've also tried to give them a
sense of what I think they could be and
I suspect that's more important in some
cases than the grant in a way it's
complemented by the grant in a way
you're giving the grant so you can
package it with this vision and the
vision will matter and the grant makes
the vision more vivid or more focal
mm-hmm like they believe the vision
because you spent real dollars on them
yeah that makes perfect sense I only
have a few questions remaining really on
my my list so to speak but I would love
to explore anything circle
that I may have missed this may sound
like a cliched question and I'm sure
that it's not going to be a new one to
my listeners but you see you think very
deeply all about a lot of things if you
could put a message a quote an image on
a billboard metaphorically speaking that
were to reach billions of people what
might you put on that billboard doesn't
have to be super short but is there
anything that comes to mind if you
wanted to impart something convey
something to billions of people what you
would say assuming they all are able to
read the same language of course well
social context is so important for
messages so as we just were saying if
you communicate to people a vision of
what they could be it needs to be
packaged with some real behavior on your
part probably to have impact and I also
as an economist tend to think very often
the market works so if I just put up on
a billboard like Tyler says do the right
thing I'm pretty sure that would be
ineffective and if you look at
billboards we actually have like what do
you see on those billboards the
billboards I see a lot of them are
advertisements for insurance some of
them are don't drive drunk you see a
bail bondsman on billboards and suicide
hotlines so I guess I would study the
market and pick one of those for things
like you know buy this insurance bail
bondsmen suicide hotline don't drive
drunk after studying the actual market
because I don't think I have some idea
that's so scarce that if it's on the
Billboard with no supporting social
context that it will mean a damn I will
say go with the market well if we take
if we take let's take a more
technologically advanced example if you
could have something pop up on
everyone's iPhone and stay there as the
background for a day really the point
are that I'm stretching for hair is to
get get getting large numbers of people
to consider a statement or a prompt of
some type for a period of time so put it
putting aside the Billboard as form
factor
is there is there anything that you've
got it you can choose not to use it but
you have the option of imparting
something via the background of
everyone's iPhones for a period of time
the people with iPhones of course I
worry about much less but I would say
this I think the social returns to
religion on average are fairly high so
the religion most likely that people
would accept in a particular area I
would want the message to be messages
about that religion so if it's the
United States that would often but not
always be Christianity again that's not
going to work in every part of the world
but I worry families are not having
enough children we're seeing
depopulation in many countries religious
families have more children religious
people tend to be somewhat happier so I
would seek that the messages would make
people more religious and you yet you
yourself are not religious but I suppose
that as that is you wouldn't choose
religion to make yourself happier
because you have very few unhappy days
but you yourself are not in a practicing
religious person I'm agnostic leaning
toward atheist so definitely not
religious was not brought up religious
my parents were not religious but I look
at the data it seems religion is the
most effective way we have of carrying
good ideas and at the margin I want to
see more of that I think also I you know
I don't do any drugs I don't drink so
some people abuse drugs and alcohol and
religion there can help so I don't have
that practical reason for needing more
religion also so let's say 10% of people
you know abuse drugs or alcohol that's a
pretty high percentage and if you think
the truly religious are less likely to
that's a big expected gain hmm well this
has been this has been very fun for me
is there anything that we have not
explored that you would like to explore
or discuss that I haven't brought up how
do you restore law
focus how do i restore lost focus yes I
would say cold exposure exercise and
having a routine that I do not deviate
from so most often for me if I feel a
loss of focus it is either their
physiological say it is theirs I'm not
eating enough I am low energy because
I've had poor sleep for a period of days
something like that almost all of which
can be remedied by attention to basic
elements of my routine so I would say
that that that's my answer if if I have
deviated from routine if I'm making too
many decisions each day that should be
replaced with some type of default
answer when I have for breakfast what
time I'm waking up where I'm going to
write or record etc that usually
Corrections they usually but often
contributes to a feeling of being
unfocused so it's it's when I abandon my
routines some of the elements of which
would be default meals and exercise and
also cold exposure first thing in the
morning restoring that order usually
helps me do you think cold exposure is
partly a placebo or talisman or you
think cold exposure works you know I
it depends in part what we mean by works
III which does it does it provide a jolt
of adrenaline and other plausible
physiological changes that seem to
contribute to more alertness yes I would
say the answer is yes
could be talisman and if by talisman we
really mean placebo effect or the desire
to feel that we are doing something to
address our problem rather than the
actual efficacy of that approach sure I
mean I think placebo effect is
everywhere so just as nocebo effect can
can affect things but
I can tell you that I find it personally
helpful but I do think there are some
certainly obvious and then not so
obvious plausible physical mechanisms
that could improve alertness when you
put yourself into 40 degree to 40 degree
fahrenheit water for a period of time
and do you fear ending up in an
equilibrium where you say no to too many
things and how do you avoid that or
maybe you just think it's not a risk
what type of equilibrium do you mean
where so we all are faced with many
demands on our time and we have to learn
to say no give a talk here visit this
yeah recruit you know whatever so we
become very good at saying no but it's
quite easy to say now once you're good
at it it's like Oh an email comes no no
and you end up saying no too much and
you end up with too little serendipity
in your life in a way you clearly would
have had at age 17 or even 23 or maybe
27 but how do you refresh the supply of
serendipity and keep the habit of saying
no to the things you ought to say no to
I do that through friends who have broad
and diverse social networks and they are
known friends of mine publicly so they
have broad social interactions and
people will pitch them on things
intended for me I like to I like my
friends to feel there is a reputational
risk / gain to making introductions or
suggesting introductions and in that
using that approach I have found that
the introductions I end up agreeing to
provide more than enough serendipity for
me and they come highly qualified and
highly vetted so I then rely on a more
perhaps systematic approach or more
tightly controlled approach to
serendipity which sounds like an
oxymoron almost versus looking for
serendipity say in my inbox or Twitter
feed I do look at I prefer to be able to
opt in to serendipity as opposed to
feeling like I'm being waterboarded with
serendipity
I also get an absurdly high volume of
inputs so that could be reflective as
you said earlier perhaps that I'm making
mistakes further upstream but I'm not
worried about equilibrium I have more
more than enough intellectual
stimulation at this point and of a
higher quality signal for me at least
you worry that too many of your friends
are highly successful people I don't
mostly because I was only referring to
my publicly known friends I don't talk I
don't talk about my non-public friends
publicly because I think that would be
opening them to all sorts of problems
that they don't want to have and I don't
want them to have so I don't worry about
that I have a lot of friends who are on
the full spectrum socioeconomically and
you know you're talking about addiction
earlier I mean my best friend growing up
was well until a few years ago my
fisherman very low income and died of a
fentanyl overdose so he would certainly
not map from a social or socio-economic
perspective on top of any portion of the
Venn diagram of the public friends that
I have so I don't worry about it too
much
I also historically travel a lot and you
know I've spent time among the homeless
in San Francisco for instance actually
paid someone to give me a sort of day
long immersion tour of like the
underground sort of economics and
dynamics of the of homelessness in San
Francisco has you said you don't have to
go to Mumbai right you can find
destitution and poverty and addiction
right around the corner if you live in
an urban center so that there are plenty
of things that I would say I worry about
I do think I probably lean towards the
worrywart side of things on the sliding
scale but I don't worry about all of my
friends being in one place or being
well-to-do or successful in quick
Marx I don't worry about that one great
yeah any other any other questions I'm
happy to field questions what's your
favorite movie my favorite movie
I've watched different movies for
different purposes I I would say that
Princess Bride the Princess Bride is
very high up I think I think William
Goldman is just a genius screenwriter
but a lot of the movies that are my
favorites and movies I've watched
hundreds of times on repeat while
writing babe would be another one I love
that yes that's or two of my favorite
movies what's your favorite movie do you
or some of yours Ingmar Bergman movies
as a whole would be my favorite part of
cinema maybe scenes from a marriage
being my all-time favorite of those but
just Empire Strikes Back is a favorite
movie so good so good it is yeah it's a
great film it's a great film Amelie
another film I love spirited away would
be one of my absolute all-time favorites
I love Miyazaki movies all of them yeah
yeah spirited away I just think has
there's a lot of metaphor and just
beautiful transformation in that movie
that I find reveals itself as you watch
it more and more so I've watched that
movie a lot and now those would be a few
those would be a few that come to mind
and then they're a bunch of flicks you
might expect I like like the first Jason
poured The Bourne Identity hint good
movie yes snatch all these movies that I
got hooked on a long time ago and
haven't been able to give up Casino
Royale I think is an exceptional film
you mean the later one not the early
David Niven one the later one yeah the
late one that's good but I do enjoy film
and fiction as a respite from the
problem solving default that I think is
a constant for me with
hyper rumination and I think that's
that's very common in people who have
suffered from say depression in the past
as I have fortunately no major episodes
in the last five or six years which I
can attribute to a few things talisman
or otherwise but or would attribute I
suppose in that case I think the ability
to for those people who are prone to
hyper in Asian which can often take the
form of an obsession with the past in
repetitive loops in the case of
depression or obsession with future
scenarios in the case of chronic anxiety
I think that I think that film and
fiction are have high medicinal value
and let's say you could put your major
commitments on hold some have freeze
time in the life you're in and take a
year off and spend it somewhere where
would you choose and why does that mean
you just come back you know we put it on
pause and you come back to the life you
have yep doesn't have to be one location
or it can it be multiple locations I can
be more than one but you can't say
everywhere right no wouldn't do it could
be well traveled down the Amazon or all
right that's multiple locations it has
to be one kind of thing one plan one
plan okay I would if it has to have some
theme I would say I would take a year
ideally with my my beloved girlfriend
and perhaps a few close friends if
possible to walk some of the pilgrimage
trails around the world
so the I've done a small portion of the
Kumano Kodo in Japan yeah um you know
that community that's not the algo is of
interest to me but extended long
duration walking with a minimum of
necessities and material goods for that
year with a minimum
of inputs I think would be be a
tremendous way to spend a year and how
much do you think we're alike versus
being different the two of us two of us
yeah
Wow that's a great question I there's a
sort of an asymmetry of information here
because I I know less about you than I
know about myself my feeling is that
we're quite yeah my feeling is that
based on I think we have many shared
interests and intellectual interests I
would say that I think you're eminently
more qualified speaking on most of these
shared interests but the the topic of
meta rationality and meta cognition
which I realize are not exactly the same
thing but very interrelated those are of
incredible importance to me and I think
about them constantly so I think our our
avenues of inquiry and interests are
very similar sounds like our hardwiring
is very different just in terms of like
this off the software that we have I
think is very different but I like those
differences I think the world doesn't
need more than one of me that's for sure
so I really revel in in the differences
I would say my impression I'd like to
hear your answer but my impression is we
probably have perhaps even more
similarities than I realize I mean I do
I am a fan of alcohol and one might even
say drugs on occasion so we have that
difference but I think those may be
largely cosmetic in some respects so
what's your impression what's what's
your what's your read I might be a bit
more mono than you are so something like
drugs if there were a safe way to do it
and probably there is I still wouldn't
do it I would figure it would distract
me from a kind of program I've set for
myself although I'm not religious I
think of my mental structure is somehow
more like Protestant and mission driven
I suspect you're more competitive than I
am hmm maybe I've tried to be less
competitive over time I've never tried
to be less competitive yeah whether or
not I should but I just think I'm less
competitive to begin with yeah that that
could be true that could be true I I
think that many of my male role models
growing up sort of surrogate influences
in that domain were coaches and so I've
I think honed much of well-honed
makes it sound all positive developed
many of my behaviors and predispositions
some I'm sure I'm aware of and some
certainly I'm not through the lens of
competition and receiving positive
reinforcement when I win so that I think
has been a huge blessing and provided a
lot from the perspective of achievement
but I do think that conditioning can be
very problematic so I envy you being
less competitive what anybody you find
of most value in religion well I I think
that sort of presumptive for me to say
in a sense because I don't I don't
consider myself religious but I think a
peace of mind with otherwise what would
be considered unknowns so frameworks for
making decisions rules that you don't
have to come up with on your own and an
assurance of plans or certain
certainties with things like death
for instance which otherwise could be
existentially overwhelming to many
people but you want to do these
pilgrimages right that's wonderful but
it's striking that that's your plan for
the year is something almost defined by
its religious nature yeah well I
they are certainly I think for some
people define the pilgrimages
are defined by some by their religious
nature I find religion endlessly
fascinating though I myself would not
self-described as religious and I also
find that I could perhaps get many of
the same benefits of doing that if I
walk the Appalachian Trail or the or one
of these other long defined paths but I
like the inbuilt social interactions of
stopping at ins or shrines etc with pit
stops along the way for reflection so I
would say that I am more a naturalist or
if I wanted to stretch and somebody said
you have to choose a religion maybe an
animist some type the izaki if you love
spirited away right yeah we resonate
with you for a reason yeah right the
that I could still find tremendous value
in pilgrimage and contemplate the deep
meaning that these paths have had for
people during very tumultuous difficult
times or times as all times are of great
uncertainty I find that I enjoy thinking
about that even though I wouldn't sort
of us I don't ascribe to any formal
religious group I thought my daughter
wants to Santiago de Compostela in Spain
and we had a fantastic time and the
social resonance of it did truly matter
for us yeah yeah absolutely and not to
get too
you can tear this apart feel free but I
feel like there is a there's a there's a
sort of a residue or a an imprint that
is made when you have thousands or
millions of people traveling the same
path that whether it's just a story you
make yourself or otherwise they're there
I've found my experiences
on those paths to be quite non-ordinary
yeah and that that's that that could get
into some pretty woowoo hand-wavy
territory really quickly but suffice to
say I just I've had very unusual
experiences on on some of these these
pilgrimage paths and I I find that
intrinsically interesting to explore if
you think about this interest in
pilgrimages the large number of guests
or people written about in your books
that you relate to and then also your
ability to quickly learn languages and
master very idiosyncratic accents and
say Spanish and German I mean do you
have a sense in your own mind of how
that all fits together like what's your
unified theory of you because those are
three very striking things about you and
maybe you've explained them somewhere
that I haven't seen or heard but this is
my chance so I'm asking you yeah so the
the we have the pilgrimages we have the
language learning and then the skill
acquisition of sort of strange
idiosyncratic eclectic things like
horseback archery but I have your book
your tools of titans and your other
books there's so many different people
you talk to or can respond with you
manage to enter into their worlds in
some way to draw them out shooting on
your podcast of course yeah so that's a
skill I pilgrimages and then the
language with highly idiosyncratic
accents done almost perfectly I might
add oh thank you for that I
but it strikes a perfect an
idiosyncratic that's unusual yeah I'm
the lightest yeah I would say that if I
had to come up with a unified theory of
Tim I've never tried before but I'll
take a stab at it and it might be very
dissatisfying
and I appreciate the questions by the
way well this is what I I think that
much like you have been had certain
software perhaps since the beginning
that enables you to be too
to handle the world with a certain
degree of equanimity I think that my
programming from the beginning has may
be very sensitive to stimuli I I think
that as a kid I was very very sensitive
not in the pejorative sense that I got
upset about things easily but rather if
I were a scale I wasn't a pound scale my
senses were more of a jewellery scale or
something like that
jewel scale excuse me so when I was a
kid I had some terrible things happen to
me and I may talk about those more in a
future episode of the podcast we'll see
but suffice to say I learned to it was
safer and better to numb myself and
desensitize myself operating in the
world and developed a lot of habits I
think competition was one high pain
tolerance related to that another that
allowed me to kind of bludgeon my
sensitivity into submission so that I
could achieve in the world and I know
this is a little long but I'll wrap it
up no this is great
which is I think all of the things you
described reflect a slow rediscovery and
reopening of those sensitivities and I
am definitely at this point an introvert
who can perform for short periods of
time as an extrovert but I find it
exceptionally energetically costly I
feel a saying it goes introverts make
the best extroverts yeah we're not
really putting ourselves out there in a
way yeah where's the extroverts it
there's so much social anxiety and
bother like being on camera
I'm taped yeah totally so yeah so I
think that that sensitivity would would
would be the unifying the unifying if
it's a unifying theory is just that I
have my
scepter is by nature very wide a very
wide perceptual aperture so I notice
things like inflection and Mandarin
Chinese or inflection in Greek or
Turkish or languages that I might just
study for a few weeks while I'm
traveling I notice things that for
whatever reason seem to only be noticed
by a small percentage of say tourists in
those places who are actively focusing
on a language and I can find a walk of a
hundred miles extremely interesting
because I notice it's not dull to me
precisely because I noticed so many
things around me but there are
environments in which if I'm noticing
the details versus using these kind of
2d Simpsons esque avatars for things it
can be very exhausting so that that's my
best stab at answering your question I
very much hope you write and talk more
about this because I think it would be
phenomenal thank you for that I
appreciate it I expect I will be writing
a bit more about it and what about
yourself I've been I know I know I'm
just reflecting back a very good
question but I'd like to get some
practice what is what is your unifying
theory the unifying theory of Tyler I
think Tyler is quite curious loves to
collect information I think in a way I'm
more an information collector than
economists or any other single thing
very even-keeled maybe just somehow
fundamentally difficult for those
reasons like hard hard to relate to
definitely introverted but sort of
always game for the next thing and I
think what I take from religion is this
Protestant notion of having a personal
project that you're obligated to see
through in a very serious way that I
find quite American and not
found in Protestantism elsewhere or even
kind of like the Jewish version of that
I'm not Jewish but there's kind of a
Jewish version of the American
Protestant sense of obligation that I
find culturally powerful and appealing
and you know I think not somehow being
involved or engaged enough is my danger
in many things but there's a kind of
thinness to myself a kind of versatility
that I can grasp onto things or work
with different people or make part of a
project work that make me very
productive and very flexible and I can
just kind of power through and keep on
going and like just not ever stop or
feel the need to or need distraction and
when I do art music theater whatever to
me it's all piling on it's not escape
from something I'm doing that becomes
too much it's like intensification so
that's like part of my theory of Tyler
but I'm also convinced like we never
know ourselves right right yeah so we
really don't and that's part of the
great tragedy of life but it also makes
life interesting yeah it's a part of the
great tragedy and also this was part of
the great incentive to find find friends
you can sit with who helped you to
discover more of yourself or develop
more of yourself not necessarily to
compensate for being unable to know
yourself completely but being a social
creature and engaging with friends more
deeply is is a relatively new thing in
my life I would say since regaining some
of the sensitivities that I'd lost so I
find the in a sense the inability to
know one's self completely a wonderful
driver to facilitate more of those deep
connections with others at least for me
that's great yeah and right go ahead go
on oh no I was just gonna say I hope
this I hope this is just the the first
of more conversations I was going to say
exactly the same so we are a bit more
alike than we thought five seconds ago I
really appreciate you taking the time
Tyler this is this has been great and I
appreciate you sort of pushing at the
edges a bit and making me think which I
always appreciate I'll be fine I will in
turn think about this all more a great
deal and I hope you do too I will I will
and people can find you at marginal
revolution calm conversations with Tyler
the podcast which I definitely recommend
people take a look at they can find you
on twitter at Tyler Cowen and I'll link
to everything in the show notes at tim
dot blog forward slash podcast for
people you can find it very easily is
there anything else you would like to
mention before we wrap up just to thank
you heartily and till whenever alright
thank you so much and to everybody
listening and possibly watching thanks
for tuning in watch out for your
talismans work on your meta rationality
and and thanks for tuning in
you